manque de considération restrictions
budgétaires dégradation des soins
voilà ce que dénoncent les internes en
médecine en grève illimitée
une grogne qui ne faiblit pas depuis les
années 70 c'est l'ensemble de la
population à l'internât quelqu'un qui
dort mal payés après ses six premières
années d'études lanternes en médecine
exerce à l'hôpital et parfois en cabinet
ou en clinique pendant trois ou cinq ans
sous la responsabilité d'un médecin
senior
il pratique des soins médicaux et des
interventions chirurgicales pour ces
internes en grève en 1976 cette
responsabilité médicale était trop peu
considérée voilà un petit peu
l'impression si vous voulez peut-être un
petit peu excessif mais que les internes
sont utilisés comme un personnel médical
bon marché un personnel médical aux
journées bien remplies parfois plus de
50 heures par semaine
en 1983 les enterre manifester encore
une fois leur ras-le-bol
parmi leurs revendications une meilleure
rémunération de leur garde
je crois que les menaces de grève
illimitée et les grèves qui commence
maintenant dans toute la france font
réfléchir effectivement les pouvoirs
publics
mais de toute évidence on voit très bien
que pour l'instant ils ne veulent
satisfaire nos demandes ça c'est une
certitude
deux ans plus tard en 1985 le salaire d
internet encore en péril les grévistes
dénoncent est alors une diminution
significative de leurs revenus
pour rappel que les internes sont des
médecins qui ont fait 7 ans d'études
supérieures
eh bien ces médecins seront pays à
partir du mois d'avril 4800 francs par
mois ça nous scandalise ça nous
scandalise d'autant plus que c'est une
diminution de 40% du salaire par rapport
à leurs aînés dans les années 90 la
colère des internes est toujours aussi
vive
les mouvements de grève se multiplient
dans toute la france en 1997 elle était
encore illimité quand les problèmes de
fond qui se posent c'est des problèmes
de valorisation de la profession en 2007
les internes continuer de se faire
entendre
après leurs salaires c'est leur liberté
d'installation qu'ils défendent est un
projet du gouvernement envisageait alors
de la limite est le principe si un jeune
médecin s'installe dans une zone où il
ya déjà suffisamment de praticiens il
n'est pas conventionné conséquence ces
patients ne sont pas remboursés par la
sécu parce qu'il faut se faire des
mesures incitatives pour qu'on aille
dans les endroits où il n'y a pas
suffisamment de praticiens et c'est pas
des mesures coercitives l'année 2012
puis 2015 seront aussi marquées par
plusieurs jours de grève des internes en
médecine avec à chaque fois le même
leitmotiv une meilleure valorisation de
la profession par les pouvoirs publics
[Musique]